Hello.
All right.
We're back.
It's been a long time.
Um.
Well, compared to our days
of daily uploading that's for sure.
Hopefully you enjoy "The Super Slow Show".
We have a lot of fun making it.
And now we're back
Uh-hm.
in the back garden with no crew
and no one to help.
It's just us.
Yeah.
We've got some lovely new equipment.
We do.
Don't worry though.
Still the same janky old table.
This is the same crap table.
So today we're testing
out two new cameras.
One very kindly provided
by Visionary Search,
which is the Phantom v2640,
which in full HD,
will do 12 1/2 thousand frames a second.
It's mental.
Um.
The highest speed we've been able to do
in HD before is 2,500.
So huge step up.
And also over here,
very kindly loaned to us by
Hasselblad is the H6D-100c,
which is a 100 megapixel
medium format stills camera.
Two very different cameras.
Because with this one
in one second I'm gonna take
12 1/2 thousand pictures.
And on this one,
I'm gonna take one,
but it'll be massive one.
So you've got a beefy picture
and a beefy frame rate
combined.
There we go.
Just beef all round.
Yeah.
So hopefully the idea
is that we'll revisit paint on a speaker
because seems like the perfect one
to revisit with slower speeds.
And you'll be able to see the
exact moment on the slow-mo
that I take this massive picture.
So I'm very excited
Yeah, me too.
I love new technology.
Before the sun graces us,
we've got some work to do.
Yeah, I've got to take this speaker
like front bit off
and use the actual comb.
Ah.
Oh this is more complicated
than I thought it would be.
Some sort of funny combing going on.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, is there screws?
Uh.
You got hit there?
Oh sort of thought.
I feel like at no point
do we correctly use any of our tools.
That worked.
Yeah.
It looked like you were about to
ax your own crotch.
Hang on.
Oh.
It's like the key.
Ah.
There we go.
That's what we need.
It's a 100 Watts,
so it should be beefy
enough for the paint.
I'll have a base of yellow.
And then the other colors
will be squirted on top.
Got some green.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
It looks like a weird paint pizza.
Okay are we ready?
Yep.
In three, two, one, now.
I forget how quickly it turns to brown.
Even though it's just pure paint.
There's no water mixed in there at all.
It just turns to brown really quick.
Ready?
Yeah.
I'm about louder in three, two, one, now.
Whoa.
Geez.
Did that get on the Phantom?
No.
That does not mess about.
That does not at all.
Oh no.
Look at this.
It's all over it.
What do I do?
Oh, oh God.
Probably deleted half
my stuff there, somehow.
It's messy work this.
We could have done with
some crew on this one.
I'd actually starting to think that.
'Cause I have to set the experiment,
hold the light, get the music right,
plug the speaker, turn it on, do that.
You're operating an
extremely complicated camera
and another extremely complicated camera.
Yeah, two very manual cameras.
Yeah.
So the idea behind using this camera
is that I'll be able to
take a 100 megapixel image
and I'm gonna set the shutter speed
to a 2000th of a second, which is maximum.
Hopefully that'll be enough.
There might be a slight bit of motion blur
because we don't have the shutter speeds
we have on the Phantom.
And my favorite thing about it,
which is amplified by the lens hood here
is the sound it makes
when you take a picture.
Have a listen to this.
Oh, you can get all of the, aw.
It's like a,
it leaves a little ringing in your ears.
So, we'll call this method stacking.
Okay.
Color stacking.
Rainbow pancakes.
Ooh, lovely.
Like a little bull's eye.
Three, two, one, go.
Holy moly.
Not only is this camera great
because it's fast at a high resolution,
but it's also very sensitive
giving us the ability to shoot
12,000 frames a second for all of this.
A T-stop of eight, mental.
And that'll give us the depth we need.
We're also using lights.
Isn't that right, Daniel?
Yeah.
That's a mega 64 hat.
Who's that?
Yeah.
It's a sun hat.
You gave it to me.
It's like you're in Fort Slow-mo.
Look at all this going on.
This is really cozy round here.
I'm like in a bit of shade.
Doing my paints.
Got my sound, my laptop.
So now we'll do a sort
of strip rainbow idea.
Yeah,
we're gonna lay all the
different colors down
in a rainbow pattern,
in lines, boom it,
and then hopefully they'll all
mix together.
Yeah.
So will do 10 mil of each color.
It's a little bit farty, isn't it?
Yeah.
It's this syringe.
It's just really like
difficult to pull up.
It's like a finger workout every time.
Okay, oh God.
All right, hope this works now.
And I don't mess it up.
That'd be annoying.
Laptop is cocked and ready to go.
Focal fingers.
Okay.
Yup.
Torches on and in.
Ready when you are ready?
Ready.
Okay.
In three, two, one, now.
I'm pretty sure that looked good.
Oh, I got it really early.
Let's take a look at that.
Oh yeah.
Put it like that.
That is sweet.
Bloody love it.
That's cool, isn't it.
Wow.
Let's actually watched
this on camera, shall we?
Yeah, sure.
All I'll be able to see is your face
when we're watching this now.
All right, hold on, look away for a bit.
I just wanna save it.
All right.
Oh, look that rising like that.
Look at that.
That is just King.
Isn't that calling.
All those colors,
you can distinctly see them as well.
Oh yeah.
That's sweet.
I like how just for one like sound,
the speaker actually moves several times.
Yeah.
I mean, it's just weird.
Like when you see sound at this level,
it's just a bunch of vibrations.
Which means that some
of the paint is going up
and some of it is coming
back down already.
Yeah.
And that meets in the middle.
Look at that.
That goes high as well.
And you can still see the distinct colors.
And now it's getting a bit more blendy-er.
Can see some of that marbling going on.
There was one glob there,
it was falling
Yeah.
and I think it had every color in it.
You know what?
That one's spinning.
That's it.
All right.
Good job I saved it.
Yeah.
Had some good practice.
Good Lord.
Even though that was great
and I shot on the Hasselblad was great.
Yeah.
I just wanna do it again.
Oh, it's so much set up for me.
It's a lot of set up.
I just think it's really good.
So much set up.
I wanna get like a top down one.
I'll come up on this.
I almost hate finding stuff that you love.
'Cause I'm gonna keep doing it.
Yeah, I'm like, oh God.
Oh, it's just great.
You can just watch that forever.
It's really cool.
It almost makes all this setup worth it.
Almost.
Almost, not quite, not quite.
All our testing for this was
done in doors, wasn't it?
Yeah.
Which means it's problems with the wind,
with stuff blown away.
I see you've taken
to using your head as a paperweight.
If I had three hands,
it would be much easier,
but I'm just struggling.
And the thing is I could help out,
but I'm just filming you.
Yeah, yeah, cheers for that.
Three, two, one, go.
We're all done.
Hopefully that was a success.
It sounded like it was.
I heard the click just
as it was quite high.
Oh it is quite high, but I like it.
Is it a good.
Yeah, I think that's quite good.
That's class.
I liked it that the torch
is putting some nice sheen on the blue.
Um, um.
It was like up here when you got that one.
I think it was higher.
Really?
Yeah.
Goodness gracious.
What?
There's a bit yellow here.
That's just like, weeeee.
So on this one, I threw
the focus to the front.
Yeah.
You've come really down on the angle.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That was a big one.
I wonder what caused that yellow,
just get out of there.
God.
Like to the moon.
What part of the speaker was like,
just you, only you.
Look at all the different colors mixing
because it's so hard to actually
just put layers of paint
because it's a liquid,
it kind of mixes already.
So there's paint underneath
each other paint.
Yeah.
Imagine working in a paint factory, right.
Where his job was to mix paint,
but it was just done with music.
That'd be a hell of a place to work.
You just get beats all day
long as part of your job.
Aww.
So that was cool there.
When everything settled for a moment.
You could actually see the
floor of the speaker again.
And then it went, boom.
It was like take that in.
Doesn't that look nice?
Lovely looking footage.
Pretty top, actually.
The only thing we haven't done
is add our sort of orange
slow-mo guys touch to it.
Well, got an idea, actually.
Kinda hungry.
We've got some cereal and milk,
but I don't have a spoon.
Are you a cereal first kinda guy
or a milk first kinda guy?
Cereal first, always.
Correct answer.
That's enough for a
hearty breakfast, I think.
This is gonna be gross.
Why?
'Cause it's milk.
What's wrong with milk?
Well, when it gets hot and sweaty.
That is pretty gross.
All right, okay.
So up until this point,
because we've been using paint
and we don't want it to just
completely bugger off immediately.
We've actually had the
volume at like six out of 10.
And I'm just gonna whack
it straight up to 11
and I haven't even seen it at 11 yet.
You gonna need earplugs.
So I've got plugs earplugs in.
Oh yeah, let's see.
Just in case it blows my face off.
Yeah.
It's three, two, one.
Oh.
Stop.
Oh, it's all over the laptop, damn it.
Oh my God.
You just you just vanished.
Oh.
Oh, it's all in my beard and horrible.
Aw, it's in my eyes.
Hold on.
Oh, what happened?
Oh, it's all in my eyes.
I'm not being funny.
I took the picture and when
I looked to you in real life,
I couldn't see your face.
I didn't need to be that
close, I don't think.
Did you eat any?
Yeah, I got something in mouth.
But I didn't get any cereal, only milk.
Just like a milk dispenser.
Oh yeah.
Can I wipe my face yet?
Yeah.
Oh not on, aw.
What else am I gonna wipe it on?
Oh, I like that.
I liked what I saw.
Me too.
I especially liked the marbling.
How the colors mingled together.
Yeah.
There was lots of good
mingling above the marble.
I think like the rainbow
one was my favorite.
Yeah, me too.
More effort to do, but totally worth it.
And that was my favorite
shot in the Hasselblad too.
Because it was right.
I thought I'd taken the picture too early,
but it was right at the perfect moment.
Yeah.
I like that we can do these things again,
but with completely new equipment.
Like we've got better frame rates.
We got the Hasselblad,
bigger speakers, more paint.
Yeah.
Honestly, revisiting our favorite videos
are the best way to test new equipment.
'Cause you have that direct comparison.
Lovely.
Hopefully you liked it too.
Feel free to follow us on Instagram.
And we have a second channel
and sweeter I guess.
See you in the next video.
Oh, for goodness sake.
Spoon eh?
You know my 'tash stinks of old milk now.
Thanks for that.